[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
شعبي الكريم انني قد قررت
ان ارد عليكم
استقالتي من منصب رئيس الوزراء
انه علينا ان الخبر وفاه الطفل ريان
منذ نهايه الحرب البارده كان الشعور العام
ان الحرب لن تترك ابواب القاره الاوروبيه
مره اخرى
[موسيقى]
اسلامي
اعلانات السعوديه انها ستسمح لما يصل الى
مليون شخص باداء مناسك الحج
[تصفيق]
الامارات
وفاه رئيس دوله الامارات
نور
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
السلاح المستخدم في قتل رئيس الوزراء
الياباني السابق في الزوابي
[موسيقى]
الى اماكن وجد فيها ايمن الظواهري زعيم
اكبر تنظيم الارهابي عرفه العالم
قابلنا رفقائه والتقينا جاره
في اوكرانيا ويبدو ان الرئيس بلاديمير
بوتن بدا يظهر بحلته الجديده في زيارات
الخارجيه
ابهلد كرافت
[تصفيق]
لماذا انهارت فشلت الهدنه في اليمن
همم لانه الهدنه قامت على ثلاثه عناصر
رئيسيه
وقع القمر بين الشمس والارض وقت الاستسرار
نهايه الشهر القمري حدث كسوف الشمس ادخلي
اتفاقي اسرائيل ولبنان حيز التنفيذ كما
اشارت مصادر الى اكتمال الترتيبات
اللوجستيه والتقنيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
بعد الملحمه الكرويه السعوديه العربيه
فوق فوق
قانون طالبان وفاه اسطوره كره القدم
العالميه البرازيليه بيليه
[موسيقى]